des logements étudiants dans le temple
protestant de Jouy-en-Josas c'est ce
projet insolite qui a retenu l'attention
du prix sésame de la Fondation du
Patrimoine en avril dernier baptisé
réjouis-toi il a pour objectif de
rénover l'édifice tout en proposant au
sein du lieu des chambres en colocation
à des étudiants ou à de jeunes
professionnels nous notre objectif c'est
l'ouverture de ce temple en vue du
logement
d'étudiants ou de jeunes professionnels
vous savez qu'il y a des besoins
considérables à proximité surjoué en
Josas et sur le plateau de Saclay remis
par la Fondation du Patrimoine le prix
sésame récompense chaque année des
initiatives locales mises en oeuvre au
sein d'édifice religieux c'est un temple
qui a une activité culturelle et puis
c'est un temple qui est ouvert pour des
activités autre que cultuelles et c'est
précisément cela que la Fondation du
Patrimoine à travers le prix sésame a
voulu récompenser l'église locale ici
souhaite s'ouvrir plus sur le monde tout
en nous continuons à renforcer les liens
entre les personnes un temple construit
en 1885 a joué en Josas après
l'installation de la manufacture de
toile de Jouy par la famille oberkamp
depuis le site n'a jamais été rénové
c'est un temple qui avait besoin qui a
souffert de l'usure du temps et qui
avait besoin d'une rénovation importante
pour le mettre à l'abri des problèmes
d'humidité pour l'isolation thermique
etc on s'est trouvé face à une situation
où le logement était vide non chauffé et
se dégradait année après année et donc
on a bien vu que c'était intéressant de
faire quelque chose et de transformer en
particulier le grenier en véritable
pièces d'habitation ce qu'il veut une
location va permettre de rembourser
partiellement l'ensemble du coup les
travaux et mais c'est surtout le projet
de vie de la paroisse commencez en mars
les travaux de rénovation du temple
devrait se terminer fin juillet 4 jeunes
colocataires seront accueillis dès la
rentrée